تداول ارواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو لاقتحام مشجعين الملعب خلال مباراه
الهلال والاتحاد والاحتفال على طريقه
رونالدو بالدوري السعودي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في مشهد مثير للدهشه وسقط مجموعه من
السياح في كاليفورنيا الامريكيه لحظه
انجاب انثى حوت رماديه ضخمه وبينما كانت
المجموعه تراقب وحوطا في الماء لاحظوا
وجود دماء فاعتقدوا ان الحوت قد يكون
مصابا الا ان المشرفين على الجوله اعلم
السياح بانها تلد
[موسيقى]
رمضان
تواصل الاجتماعي مقطع فيديو لمواطنين
لبناني يعثر على كنزه المخبا داخل شجره
الزيتون وكان بداخلها كميه من العملات
القديمه اخفاء احدهم داخل الشجره قبل
عقودا في منطقه العباسيه جنوبي لبنانيه
للمشاهد
الله
يا الله
بنت لبنان وسوريه خمس ليرات وليره ليره
ليره
ان شاء الله هيدا كاين في ايامه ملياردير
صراحه
ما بعرف الله يرحمك من كبد الله
بطبيب الباكستاني متزوج من ثلاث زوجات
يستقبل مولوده 60 ويستعدوا للزواج للمره
الرابعه لانجاب المزيد من الاطفال الطبيب
الباكستاني يدعى سردار جان يبلغ من العمر
52 عاما ويعمل طبيبا بعياده يديرها منزله
وعلى نجانا عن خطته لانجاب ما لا يقل عن
100 طفل وانا امنيته ان تكون لديه بنات
اكثر من الابناء وان يضع عائلته باكملها
في منزل واحد
[موسيقى]
كان هذا كل شيء اليوم الى اللقاء